hallo mein name ist im konter in den
letzten zwei drei tagen kamen auf meinem
kanal keine videos meine ich könnt euch
jetzt sagen wo ich hatte so viel zu tun
und da hatte ich so viele termine und
das ist alles passiert aber es war
karneval und ich habe mich gemault das
war das ja meine kompletter oberschenkel
ist blau aber meine damen und herren
nach dreitägiger abschnitts von dieser
plattform habt ihr mich jetzt wieder an
der backe und zwar mich ein video
gesehen was mein bester freund ein blatt
vor einiger zeit hochladen hat uns weit
er sich selbst gegoogelt
quality content ich habe das ganze vor
einem halben jahr selbst schon mal
gemacht und hab mir jetzt heute einfach
mal gedacht es könnte ja mal gucken ob
da vielleicht irgendwas dazu gekommen
ist
also wir befinden uns hier schon auf
google warum ist eine fucking
schildkröte
[Applaus]
ok
das ist jetzt olympia spiel oder was auf
jeden fall gehen wir jetzt erstmal
kontraste ein leerzeichen das erste was
kommt es konkreter pizza weil meine
damen und herren ich hab schon eine
pizza rausgehauen demnächst kommt
eventuell eine zweite pizza
das contra flug als mein name ist khan
crafter shop ich meine freunde kennt
alle top adresse mein buch concept a
pizza rewe edeka pizza kaufen alter
nachname und größer also sind jetzt
nicht so krasse sachen aber wir können
nur einen geben crafter ist und dann
sehen wir tot
[Musik]
ich bin natürlich nicht ohne meine damen
und herren dann sehen wir aber auch noch
kompakter ist illuminati was nämlich
nicht konkreter wtf ist dass minecraft
kontrast wann es konkreter geboren wie
es konkret auf seinen namen gekommen
habe ich das hoch unglaublich viele
leute immer fragen auch mal bei
instagram instagram hat sich übrigens
laser luca also da könnt ihr auch gerne
folgen ich habe schon unglaublich häufig
erklärt allerdings jetzt noch mal für
alle die irgendwie keine orden haben ich
hatte früher einen kanal der hieß
concours lp und da bin ich auf den namen
gekommen weil ich ein spiel gespielt was
komme den kongress und dann hab ich
gedacht komm her konkret econ terror lp
dann hab ich mal allerdings gedacht okay
ich möchte neuen kanal aufmachen und
konkreter name finde ich gar nicht mehr
so geil nehme ich einfach nur das konto
von ein paar kraft dahinter weil ich
eigentlich nur minecraft hochladen
wollte wm fahren ich die kombination aus
c&c ganz cool und hatte damals auch
schon logo wo die beiden csu
untereinander waren und dann dachte ich
halt für instagram okay da will ich
jetzt nichts mit kraft einmal da mach
ich ja keine kraft sondern da bin ich ja
ich selbst also luca deswegen ja nicht
mich da laser luca wahrlich l und l
haben wollte ja das ist die komplette
story und ich glaube die jetzt machen
wir das sie allerdings mal weg und geben
mal ein luca leerzeichen da kommt zuerst
mal eine pizza dann mein job dann luca
hänni luca toni
luca meerbusch die soll ich denn noch
meerbusch haben als ich jetzt gerade
schon habe ich gebe jetzt mal einfach
ein konkreter hat da kommt als erstes
konnte haye hat crafter eine freundin
hat contractor geschwister snapshot jahr
snapshot laser luca 100 kontrakte
geburtstag 21 februar in elf tagen
in elf tagen was denkt ihr mir
eigentlich zum geburtstag 10 euro oder
200 euro wandert congo after seinen
kanal erstellt kommt ja auch noch keine
ahnung irgendwann so vor fünf jahren
oder sogar crafter twitter größe und
buddy
ey
wie oberflächlich sind ja diese ganzen
suchanfragen ich dachte da kommt jetzt
war svww hat contractor gefühle oder was
für eine scheiße aber was mich auf jeden
fall mal interessieren würde es hat
kontraste eine freundin weil das ist so
das ok hat das video habe ich mal dazu
gemacht bettgeflüster bei kontrast zeigt
er uns eine
freunden zeigt er uns hier seine
freundin viele fans scheint sicher die
person im bett ist lukas freundin wird
was für eine person im bett eine frage
der 21-jährige youtube ein echter mensch
etwas lahm an die hier für eine scheiße
alter bla bla bla bla hier ich weiß
nicht wie man auch so was so fit machen
ab in die musikbranche bringt contract
arbeit eigene single auf etwas das ist
voller schöne bild von der 1live krone
eigentlich aber okay ab in die
musikbranche blablabla kraft unterstützt
seinen kumpel felix jenes nach youtube
die musik der nächste schritt
laserdrucker plant vorerst keine eigene
single am ende leider keine guck mal da
steht im titel kommen lukas eigenes sind
single und dann steht da drin luca plant
eine eigene single ich will mal sehen
was passiert wenn ich jetzt einfach luca
ein gebe da kommt tatsächlich als erstes
luca der vorname dann okay hier kommen
kommt als autor
also ja
stimmt luca to go roger fahrt dann kommt
ihr tatsächlich schon ein eigener kanal
und sogar schon ein eigener shop alter
wenn man einfach nur luca einige das
schon geil ist konkreter tod das hat mir
glaube ich letztes mal auch schon mal
waren es konkreter geworden kommt dass
da eigentlich
besteht genau drin ich gehe jetzt hier
auf contra ist illuminati von craft das
seminar tick entfernt ich weiß nicht ob
wir uns das video schon mal angeguckt
hat und dabei kommt glaubt dass name ist
luca luka lukrative buchstaben
ich glaube das hat man schon mal
angeguckt 542.000 aufrufe
vielleicht sollte ich mal video auch so
nennen hier habe ich eine illuminati
zieht vorgestellt wie gut kennst du
karton kann ich will mal sehen was bei
den news kommen wenn ich mich da ein
gebe jeder hier ist nackt youtuber
geschockt von chat experiment ist das
neueste das ist sechs tage alt da habe
ich auf chatroulette nur nackte menschen
gesehen ein welcher deutsche youtuber
steckt hinter diesem süßen blonden
kreischalarm youtube.com crafter
verschenkt diese ja ein bisschen spät
dran
mein name ist luca zweites buch von
congo after kontrakte bei seinem pc
release darum streich wie die komplette
video einnahmen jedoch pizza popularität
allein reicht nicht aus so genial für
anstand youtuber baby ja lesen kann ich
katja krawitz hatte sex mit bekanntem
youtube-star den namen sagt katja nicht
aber die fans glauben zu wissen wer es
ist der name von luca krankhafter fällt
sehr oft auf luca kommen die fans weg
hat ja als sanel einen käufer pixel hat
der luca super ähnlich doch katja
schreibt man leute kaum kraft da war es
nicht war
an der stelle wird das video ist
allerdings auch beende meine damen und
herren ich bin noch nicht wieder
komplett fit von karneval wir waren
relativ lang unterwegs und ich habe mich
auch echt wer hält das da hat schon sehr
weh getan wie ich mich gebaut habe wenn
euch dieses video allerdings gefallen
hat würde ich mich sehr sehr dort war
ein leid von euch freuen einem schreibt
wir wollen in die kommentare ob ich
morgen wieder einen gepard bringen soll
dann werde ich noch mal zu mal
[Musik]